[Applause]
so my co-host tonight comedian Matt
kirshen Matt one of the comedy writers
on the Jim Jefferies show and you're
also the host of the podcast probably
science you go for the definitely we
keep the probably in there yeah I want I
said I'll come back on the show when you
becomes definitely science rather than
probably science I'll take it
also joining us we need somebody with an
expertise in this is medieval expert
Russia
Kiriko Chien Russia welcome good
professor of German and the study of
religion at Harvard University thanks
for coming down from Cambridge to New
York and you you teach a class called
the real Game of Thrones
culture society and religion in the
Middle Ages just setting the record
straight yeah that's correct
didn't there do you say there are no
dragons I'm gesturing yes I'm gonna be
honest this is the first time I've
realized that Game of Thrones isn't real
we'll be tapping your expertise tonight
as we feature my interview with the
creator of a pop culture Empire this
sci-fi fantasy author george RR martin
and he worked the best-selling fantasy
series a Song of Ice and Fire and that
was adapted into the world's most
popular TV drama Game of Thrones and
characters in this story they fight for
an Iron Throne with swords and shields
but also with dragons and zombies right
so i asked george RR martin about
blending fantasy with the real world so
let's check that out
Game of Thrones is largely based on on
medieval history so but it is a fantasy
my technique on a lot of it was to you
know to find some real element of
history some real event or a castle or
something and then to turn it up to 11
or 12 or 13 or 14 you know I like the
the ice wall the wall of the North had
was inspired many years ago when I
visited Hadrian's Wall and I stood on
Hadrian's Wall as the Sun was going down
and most of the tourists have left
during the day I pretty well have it to
myself and
was blowing and I was trying to imagine
what it'd be like to be a Roman
legionaries stationed there and and
looking at these hills so north and
wondering what might emerge from them to
attack the wall because they kind of
thought of it as the end of the world or
at least that was the myth but of course
then I turned it up to eleven and twelve
and instead of ten feet tall I made it
seven hundred feet tall and I made it
full of ice and you know five times as
long as Hadrian's Wall is you know
because it's spanning a much larger
continent and that's the same technique
you do for a lot of fantasy stuff you
always want the fantasy to be bigger and
bolder and more colorful than than the
real life that being said I also and
maybe this is my again my penchant
toward a certain amount of realism that
I didn't want to go all the way into
crime magic a game of Thrones compared
to other fantasies is a very low magic
fantasy magic is there its present and
we have magical beasts like the Dragons
and there's certain sorts of magical
things going on but it's it's not high
magic and in that in the circumstance I
took my inspiration from junior our
token if you actually look at lurid
rings as suffuse as it is with magic
there's very little onstage magic you
know Gandalf is a wizard but when orcs
attack he draws his sword and he fights
just like the the people next to him he
doesn't just go and the right magazine
is all about the end of the movies right
so you know that's the kind of stuff I I
do with it a wild fire which is another
of the quasi magical things is you know
plays especially a big part in the
Battle of the Blackwater it was partly
inspired by the legend so Greek fire
that the Byzantines used you know which
supposedly we've never been able to
duplicate that Byzantines kept it a
secret they used this Greek fire on
attacking fleets from other nations and
somehow the secret was lost and now we
don't know what was in Greek fire but
you have resurrected
yeah it's a little bit Greek fire it's a
little bit napalm it's a little bit
nitroglycerin it has to cool this
characteristics and it's it's jade-green
it burns with green flames why because I
thought that would be cool and indeed
where we started and film it was really
cool yeah there are chemicals that will
emit only green light so it's very food
you can just say that's in the in the
mixture and your your good for my tweets
right sriracha which says Game of
Thrones is is based on medieval history
could you just straighten this out um is
I this is the Middle Ages the Dark Ages
where what is medieval history just set
that record straight for all of us once
and once there forever just yes right so
the first issue that we have to bear in
mind really is that the term Middle Ages
is mostly not only but mostly connected
to European history so that's the first
thing to bear in mind
I don't do other parts of the world
could have different yeah periods it
might call Middle Ages exactly they
divided into different periods so um
then when it comes to Dark Ages the
scholar of the Middle Ages will scarcely
refer to any period of time as Dark Ages
because no period was actually dark and
so usually Dark Ages you mean where
there was no science it is dark but I've
always been like what kind of science we
are exactly the thing is with Dark Ages
usually it's it's used to denote a non
Roman world before the ascent of
Christianity and you take that
definition you you see how erroneous it
actually is because they've always been
high civilizations also in the early
Middle Ages let's think about Muslim
Spain right across the Mongolian Empire
uh-huh right so that's that's that's the
other thing and then when it comes to
when half the Middle Ages actually begun
when have they ended Minds differ on
that usually we say the fall of Rome and
then when it ended
maybe when Columbus stumbled upon
America or did they actually ever end
that's the other question and have the
Middle Ages ever ended because societies
you see
shift unitedly and the middle ages end
for different parts of the populations
at different times where we take women's
rights children's rights equality before
the law regardless of ethnicity or
believe we realized that the middle ages
have lasted far into the 20th century
also in Europe I thought there was gonna
be a simple answer yeah 16:24 no you're
like oh actually no we are still in the
dark ages a lot and uh so Matt would you
go back to the medieval times I mean I
don't know I think I don't think I don't
think either of us would fare well I
mean sort of a black man asking a Jewish
guy how oh yeah let's go back to
medieval times let's see how that works
out
but here's the other thing here's the
other problem you'd have back in the day
if you went to medieval times there's
there's no Twitter I do so live without
Twitter could you yeah oh because we
investigate it we actually found out
this is what we think your Twitter
account would look like back in medieval
days well it's actually hey hey before
every tweet here hehe if he took a bath
every now and again lots of you would
stop dying from the plague oh very good
yeah I would tweet that maybe yeah so so
Game of Thrones is all about like a
ruthless battle for the Iron Throne and
my buddy Bill Nye recently claimed that
throne himself and sent us a Startalk
dispatch let's check it out
iron weapons swords especially had
changed the course of human history both
here in the real world where you and I
live and on the game of Thrones and if
you want an iron sword first you need
iron and you get that from a mine or a
peat bog and before there was dynamite
that was not easy believe me but
blacksmiths then take the iron and cook
in a tiny bit of carbon and blacksmith
do that so that they get a very hard
sharp edge backed by a relatively
flexible broad
part anyway once you have that nice
sharp edge with the flexible back you
can just start slinging and swinging
your sword around to you eviscerate or
decapitate everyone you meet till they
either give up or die or both after you
do that
this baby's all yours well back to you
Neal or Sir Neal I don't know I'm just
seeing it already go to bills head well
next we will discuss the science of
fire-breathing dragons when Startalk
returned we're talking about the real
science and history behind HBO series
Game of Thrones featuring my interview
with author george RR martin check it
out when I watch Game of Thrones I maybe
I pay attention to different things than
other people do I'm looking at the
anatomy of the dragon I'm saying is this
legit and and I had I think I tweeted
once I complimented the dragon sports
yes I like that to read that was good so
it was I just wanted everyone to know
that whatever other fantasy you're
observing the dragon has biological
skeletal authenticity because anything
that flies in this world had to forfeit
its four limbs to do so right you get a
plus good I mean this is a real dispute
in in dragon things so I'm always been
interested on the two legged dragon but
there are the four legged dragon things
and in heraldry of course I've learned
with reading these books a fair amount
about middle heraldry the the two legged
dragon is not a dragon it's a wyvern and
only the four legged dragon on a
heraldic shield is counted as a dragon
so I have the heraldic purists on my
I live my whole life and I did not know
this yeah we gotta bring it a new guest
to get to the bottom of this stuff so
joining us now for a discussion on
dragons is paleontologist mark Norell
division chair and McCawley curator of
paleontology right here at the American
Museum of Natural History
he wants a curated an exhibit on mythic
creatures and exacta the exhibit
companion book here mythic creatures and
you're a co-author on this yes and so
what's the connection between
paleontology and Dragons well I think it
could be one of many things I mean it's
like that certainly that that you know
dragons or giant reptiles of some kind
or Universal almost all cultures but at
the same time I mean dragons mean really
different things depending on the
culture you're from and that you know in
the West it's always like you know awful
stuff like their guardians of virginity
and tombs and the gold all these kinds
of things so Stan's had to slay them but
in the east you know the dragons are
simple which is really great that's why
every wants their kid to be born in a
dragon you're in China and Japan and
Thailand everywhere else but what does
that have to do with fossil evidence of
dinosaurs
well it's certainly people in the past
like knew much more about the anatomy of
like animals than people do now we go to
the butcher shop we buy stuff is
prepackaged and stuff refers have to
slay their animals so they find like
fossil bones that in the old days they
would like you know see that yeah this
is really unlike the sheep we just
killed for dinner last night so they
there would be this kind of like legacy
kind of systematics that they make up
stories to explain what was going on
because presumably that's how you making
connections
yeah but certainly we know that a little
bit from Europe because like in Crete
and other places that there was like
ministry elephants that were found and
did it nobody had ever seen an elephant
skull before if you all you guys out
there had never seen an elephant skull
before that you saw one and it has a big
hole in the middle
which is where the the trunk attaches
and stuff so there's actually Greek
bases that show these and say this is
the head of the Cyclops oh so I mean I
guess whether the the myth of Cyclops
exists before that or that happened
because of these finds nobody really
knows but you know we know that people
in antiquity looked at fossils and they
were able to make some stories about
them
so Russia George Martin mentioned
heraldic purists who used dragons on
their coat of arms what what can you
tell us about that heraldry is for
example coat of arms is part of heraldry
it starts as a visual literacy so you
imagine you in the battle and everyone
looks a bit the same or kind of male
clad in mail kite armor how do you
distinguish foe from friend you need
some sort of a sign and that sign needs
to be actually simple right so you can
actually catch it immediately so that
was the initial idea of heraldry then in
tournaments which are not about life and
death they became more intricate because
it was not so much about actually
recognizing who's who's in your unit and
who's not
dragons have different dragons and
heraldry have different background
stories and mark already explained some
of them and certainly in English coat of
arms the dragon also comes into it
because of the legends that surround st.
George the patron saint of England who's
said to have slaughtered a dragon so he
he went out with a with a white coat of
arms so he didn't have a specific sign
and and and killed a dragon that was
that was just passing or so he said that
is my patron saint and if he said he
killed a dragon he killed a dragon and
so what happened the dragon's blood
splashed a cross on his on his shield
and that red cross is of course the flag
of England I should have known that and
I didn't so so I think the scariest
dragon on Game of Thrones it's got to be
the zombie ice dragon yeah
that this is just just look at this
thing and so I asked George our Martin
about the origin of the idea said the
ice dragon let's check it out
I wrote a book one before Game of
Thrones my don't want children's book
I've written the ice dragon which is the
dragon that breathes cold instead of
instead of fire and you know freezes
things that you know the cold is just
equally deadly comes over you and you're
frozen and then you split her into it
million pieces because you've been
dropped into liquid oxygen or something
like that so I think the ice dragon was
my original contribution to the fantasy
best theory so there is sort of my kazoo
of fantasy creatures and it'll be in
there in the books I do have the dragons
are various different colors and the
color of their flames varies with the
color of the Dragons so you know
balerion the black dread they're
probably the biggest and meanest dragon
in the history of Westeros his black and
his flames are black hmm and they're
really really hot they'd you know at one
point there's the Lord who says well I
don't care you know you have a dragon
but I have a stone castle and stone
doesn't burn and well stone will melt if
the flames are hot enough cold lava yes
and that's what he discovers exactly if
your castle melts give up
so mark what other fossils have sort of
contributed to this bestiary of fantasy
creatures well there's a really famous
fossil called Protoceratops and it has a
remarkable resemblance to Griffin's
remind me of Griffin is a lion with
wings yeah right yeah it's like it's
like mermaids and it's like you know
dragons every culture seems to be a
universal every cultures invented these
since independently you know what was
the spark of that we really don't know
but certainly because it has very
different meanings well I think we can
say this independent origin interesting
my ask about the army of undead corpses
that he created for a game of Thrones
let's check it out if I just landed on
earth and I saw them I have to call them
zombies they were dead and now they're
alive well they're moving they're alive
I mean obviously when you die you know
if I if I die you know five minutes from
now and oh I ever heard of that guy
follow I'm dead on the floor my body is
still there
my body is still there and and some
force can animate it in principle and
bring it up and get it get it going
again send electricity I mean it said
what what moves our arms it's electrical
impulses from our brain and and all of
that so if the impulse has come from
somewhere can't and our arms move and
all that you know it's the Frankenstein
thing this is what inspired Mary Shelley
to write Frankenstein was she read about
the experiments where dead frogs
if you poked up with electricity their
legs jumped her so Frankenstein comes
from that and okay so they are just
reanimated dead people yes essentially
we need some extra expertise for this
one there all right we need some zombie
expertise so joining us for the science
of the undead is Steve Schlossman Steve
aka dr. zombie your professor of
psychiatry at Harvard Medical School and
yeah you wrote the zombie autopsies
which is a fictional medical journal of
zombies yes a matter of fact the medical
school requires me to tell folks it's
fictional like I'm actually you I'm not
making this up the Dean has mandated
that I say the zombies are not real yet
but they're not real that sounds like
something dr. zombie might say so George
Martin says that some force could in
principle reanimate his dead body
so how true a statement is that I'm
imagining of course within a certain
amount of time you can be reanimated but
then we don't call you a zombie we can
stop your heart there was a day when
they just said you were dead and then a
minute later bring it back now you're
alive again but you're not a zombie so
at what point are you just alive again
and at what point are you a zombie
so organs all have different viability
and when they stop receiving oxygen
through the blood and they start to make
their way from aerobic to anaerobic
States many of those organs remain
viable for a long time that's what we
can harvest organs which is not a term
we use so much anymore but use them for
transplants including the brain right
now we you know we're not there
obviously but we can do things we can
use brain signals to move cursors on a
screen we can use brain signals to move
automated limbs even though they're not
connected to the brain it's it's like a
Bluetooth moving an arm that's pretty
amazing what is the mechanism so you
have the somatosensory cortex which is
still working but these are a spinal
cord injuries right so as much as the
motor cortex region in the brain wants
the left arm to move it can't get the
signal there because the spinal cords
been severed but it can send an
electrical signal literally a Bluetooth
to the muscle here cause that muscle
through electrical impulses just like
mr. Martin was saying to ms was an
electromagnetic signal exactly is sent
over there so so I'm curious aside from
using electricity or magic is there some
disease that can produce a zombie
outbreak like the kind we see in the
movies we don't have anything that
exactly mimics the the sort of zombie
infection that George Romero's so
famously invented 1968 what night Living
Dead we just don't have that but we can
have aspects of it we make people lose
their balance we do that with booze
right but we can also do it with germs
we can make people full of Rage with
bugs like rabies you can make people
lose their capacity to open doors open
windows to think clearly with things
like Christ oh yeah copes disease that
the hard one is to make you hungry
that's a hard one you think about when
you've been sick like really sick with a
fever
you're usually lose hunger there's some
viruses adenovirus which is just a cold
virus but in some people it messes with
the hypothalamus and makes you forget
that you've eaten enough and you keep
eating so there's some infectious agents
that actually increase obesity Wow so
you have a whole whole catalogue of
these infectious agents that do
different things to different purges of
the human body oh yeah okay now do any
can any of them reanimate a dead body
nope we're not there yet yeah so you
said yeah yeah okay and he also said we
need for my community of scholars dr.
Zee makes me sound like a rapper
something Russia is there are there Game
of Thrones type zombies and any medieval
literature or cultures or legends I'm
really glad you say Game of Thrones type
zombies because not the zombies we have
grown to be accustomed to
thanks to fantasy literature and fantasy
films but actually when you think of
what we just discussed zombies being
basically reanimated matter that's
action
the core of the Christian belief think
about it resurrection and it's the
judeo-christian believe the resurrection
of the body the resurrection of the
physical matter and in this vain
shedding her first Jesus was a zombie
actually I've been Army writes the
heavenly host seven army of zombies
right now okay I didn't say that what I
was born in the same in the in the same
vein and we have legends of martyrs
veins whose body parts that were cut off
or tortured we reappear physically
reappear but that's a mark of the
sainthood and mostly these these body
parts do not decay which is also mark
off the sainthood so these are early
zombie concepts well there's another
power mystical power in Game of Thrones
is the ability of some characters to
become an animal by taking over their
mind so let's check it out skin walking
shape-shifting in honor various words
for it in various legends in various
cultures as the navajo have a have a
version of their here in new mexico and
of course it existed in in europe in
various forms but again how about how to
do this realistically i think the actual
bodily change where you know that the
bones get longer and the mass gets
heavier and the whole body rearranges
well it's it's cool for our story and
i've used it that but it didn't seem to
fit in Game of Thrones so I thought well
this skin-changer would be would be
someone who actually moves his
consciousness into a into another thing
not that his body actually changed but
he got his mind into an eagle or or a
wolf or had some bond with them and I
tell you how brilliant that is because
what it took us a while to learn and to
embrace but that objects that have
physical existence that's one thing but
the concept of information doesn't
have the same constraints of a physical
object plus it's valued differently
right so I can give you two oranges and
you have two oranges but if I give you
two newspapers you don't have twice as
much information no it's the same
information but duplicated so and we've
also found that unless one of them is
two times and one of them is the arrow
is like that then you have a completely
different word so for you to transfer a
consciousness in a way you're
transferring information right is that
that is completely plausible relative to
your right bones growing like the Hulk
of becoming the Hulk well where did that
extra mass come from right you have you
have issues I mean in some ways the
ability to transfer your memories
transfer your consciousness into
something else is is the possibility of
you know immortality if you if your
memories survived then you survive your
your personality whether it's in a robot
body or a clone body that we grow I mean
science fiction has done many different
ways if you assume of course that that's
really you that somebody's been my issue
with the Star Trek transporter okay they
disintegrate your body correct and at
the end they put together a new body
from random atoms that they get and it
has your memory and it thinks it's you
but is it really you
Steve if you transfer your consciousness
is it still you if you transfer your
consciousness is it still you no no
actually because the U has changed from
the time that you did the transfer to
the time it's received right it was your
consciousness Wilson's consciousness is
it so it's a different consciousness
that's a different you so consciousness
technically folks say has to have three
things it has to be qualitative so it's
not measurable it's the concept of being
like something it's subjective so the
subject experiences it and it's unified
like I'm not thinking about the feeling
of my butt in this chair except that I
just said it so now I'm thinking about
it feel my button this chair
all those things have to come together
combined with my memories and my thought
of what's going forward you take my
conscious it out and put it into you now
I'm thinking of what your butt is like
in that chair I don't mean that in any
sort of untoward way I'm thinking about
so suddenly that's a new consciousness
that's what's so interesting about the
concept that he created in this story so
it's not just a consciousness that had
extra stuff that happened to it extra
life experience you're saying it's a
whole new consciousness wha yeah I'm
curious Racha
is there a in medieval history is there
any accommodation for the transference
of mind in religion for example sort of
especially in religion actually there
are mystical traditions according to
which a soul can be so connected to the
divine that it can get the qualities of
the divine including looking into the
future looking into the past looking
into the present time but seeing other
spaces that the actual physical body is
in now telepathy telekinesis were not
categories that maybe evil people
operated on but they rather talk to
visions and prophecies yes of course
it's full of nothing so surprising okay
so here's the question then Steve what's
more likely to happen first reanimated
dead bodies as zombies or transference
of consciousness honestly I think
transference of consciousness because as
we get better at mapping the way the
brain works we can then translate that
into the ones and zeros that we make
things like our smartphones possible and
then
if anyone's watch black mirror in any of
these shows it is watch Game of Thrones
we know that we can start to then create
a cookie of ourselves in in ways that
are both horrifying but also kind of
invigorating when you think about it
because then you can start to think
about suffering and inaugurated in the
same set I'm very sure that's the motto
of his lab where they do I didn't say we
yes well I actually think we'll be there
i some ways were we're there rich okay
when you get there can you come back on
the show I would be honored well dr.
zombies thank you for joining us tonight
on Startalk up next we discovered
fantasy author George RR Martin's early
sci-fi inspirations when star George RR
martin and i asked where his passion for
science fiction writing began check it
out biggest influence for was comic
books superman and batman and you know
all the other comic books of the day you
know the kitty books and of course the
superheroes most of all it was before
Marvel initially but I read those DC
superheroes books and that was much more
interesting you know fighting the Joker
or the Riddler or Lex Luthor other
planets Krypton blowing up I mean it's
my introduction to astronomy you're
gonna gotta watch out you know if your
planets could have blow up you put the
kid in this little space shoot and you
shoot a wolf at the outer space and hope
that someone finds him we didn't have to
term astronaut they invented that term
with the mercury seven nobody had ever
heard of astronauts before the mercury
program they were spaceman you know and
there were a lot of shows on TV about a
spaceman you know Tom Corbett space
cadet captain video rocky Jones Space
Ranger you know and I watched all of
these shows and
I did an encyclopedia of space here
where I combined my fictional creations
here with uh with real creations I
designed my own solar systems and then I
had two real solar system these so these
are from the 1950s
yes see here's the real solar system Wow
okay I did a map and who's the Sun
Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter and
here remember this one no we would not
we're not going here and then I inside
the fictional cellar say here's alpha
century's fictional solar system where I
invented weird-ass names for the the
planets woody Hosmer which I obviously
got from Oz throg I don't know where I
got that uh you know mm and then I had
little entries here where you can read
all about them
these are the real things that I looked
up here is some more there you go for
another I graduated to color color up so
it looks like your imagination had
higher precision than your ability to
color in a circle George this goes on
and on these are continents and oceans
and sure so yeah it's really a throg and
what kale are so it's a great name and
how old are you in this you're an
elementary school yes yes definitely
elementary school I take the back you
are not a normal kid okay probably not
by joining us to discuss George RR
Martin's geeky origins is start talks
resident deacon chief astrophysicist
Charles Liu JA your professor at CUNY
Staten Island yes and a good friend and
colleague of mine so so what do you
think of a space encyclopedia I think it
was perfectly normal kid I had one too
mine was more about spaceships it was
and so you kept a notebook like that
yeah what was actually a file folder it
was like a he'll wander loose paper in
it I wasn't as sophisticated as he was
and so what was what were your what were
your pages oh they were mostly about
spacecraft I was inspired by the 1970s
movie Battlestar Galactica okay and what
I would draw was like well this ship
could go this fast and had this much
firepower and could contain as many
people that sort of thing so he's
perfectly normal I promise I mean that
is you he's normal is this the measure
of things
so Charles in Game of Thrones mhm the
the winter and summer seasons for
Dickey's
yes so I tried to imagine a planetary
system that could be that and I just
gave up and I saw them just enjoy the
show use the trick about that season
stuff and I've thought about this you
can see the seasons not only are they
long they are also unpredictable
sometimes it can be only a few years
other times they can be lifetimes to be
a chaotic orbit right so if you talk to
only about astronomical orbits you
couldn't imagine a a strong processional
tilt you could imagine multiple planets
doing some sort of chaotic activity but
really there's got to be something else
that's changing the timescales on like a
decade like level as opposed to this
world resident lenio global warming very
volcanic activity or other kinds of
particulates that perhaps the solar
system is moving through in its host
galaxy so it would not be an orbital
phenomenon it would be a local
phenomenon to the climate yes you have
to add in something in the atmosphere
and in the oceans surrounding Westeros
in order to create these kinds of
unusual climate situation well I asked
him how
his early interest in science helped him
shape his writing career because that
one can influence the other so let's
check it out I've never been a hard
science writer you know I didn't I'm
like I said science was hard but maybe
because I grew up reading and writing
science fiction there's always been
something about me that applies a
certain level of realism to whatever I
do one of my books before ice and fire
was fever dream which was my historical
horror novel set on the Mississippi in
1857 but vampires and I did a lot of
research for that and I'm reading all
this stuff about vampires and then I
said well okay how am I going to do my
vampires you know I looked at all the
vampire legends and I went through them
okay they can't come out in sunlight I
can make that work you know they're
they're very photosensitive their skin
burns or something like that they're not
reflected in mirrors no I can't make
that work I mean that's that's just
ludicrous why are they not reflected in
mirrors advisor violates everything we
know about light and all that so I I
rationalized my vampires as much as I
could possibly rationalize them and made
them it's not quite science fictional
vampires certainly more realistic
vampires than those in many other works
and when I get to dragons this is the
same thing I looked at these dragons and
yeah I can't claim to be scientifically
rigorous they still breathe fire I mean
there's no way there's no way you can
get around the breathing of fire allow
me to put you at ease okay I'm a big fan
of for me a famous quote from Mark Twain
which every artist needs to take to
heart and you clearly have it is first
get your facts straight then distort the
Metra leisure exactly yeah so you have
your basic anatomical dragon haven't
breathe fire we're good with that
there's certain things you need you need
- dragon has to breathe fire the vampire
has to drink blood in
right the other stuff you can fiddle
with as Esme be controlled as scientist
can we get so embedded in reality that
would prevent us from writing a good
sci-fi story we could but good
scientists avoid that Albert Einstein
said it really well in 1932 he said that
the feeling of being awed by the
mysterious things of the universe
duska feud the kiss geheime miss fallin
is this a German is it okay yeah it's
the few discs hymen is fallen is the
thing that powers all great art and
science Jeffery Landis PhD in space
science great science fiction writer
David Brin PhD also great science
fiction writer and who can forget Isaac
Asimov one of the greatest sources
there's all chloride PhD scientist
Pristina biochemistry that is worse so
not at all should there be any siloing
between people who do science and people
who don't because that same origin of
energy is where we get all of our ideas
and imagination and the moving forward
for discovery hmm it's the same for
fantasy authors when you think about it
really fantasy became a genre was
talking okay before he was a medievalist
and he was a academic he was an academic
medievalist in the same sees Lewis who
wrote The Chronicles of Narnia and they
were actually friends both of them were
professors for medieval English Wow it's
a wizard when's your story coming up
we'll watch for that Charles thanks for
joining us today my pleasure argh thank
you Steve always good to have Chara
and I asked about the portrayal of
violence in his hit series Game of
Thrones had to go there check it out
Game of Thrones the TV show Chris has
adapted from my book so there these
these elements were there in my books to
begin with at that extreme yes and no in
some ways more extreme in other ways
less I mean there's something about
seeing something that makes it more
different visceral than just that's
reading about it but obviously I wanted
to include sexuality I mean it so one of
the usual one of the driving forces of
all of us that didn't governs our
decision making it a shaped history and
violence was you know it's a war story
and a lot of fantasy the great epic
fantasies are war stories Tolkien's is a
war story you're right all of these are
war stories tells a stupid question
because it seems to me that if you're
writing a war story like the word vice
the word violence should have come out
you're absolutely know I'd say all the
great epics somebody's fighting somebody
and somebody's dying whole tribes are at
war that is that's there but no I don't
object to the word violence at all I
think it's a good honest word working on
that show gave me a real really brought
home to me this this hypocrisy about
action versus violence you know we we
want to show people killing each other
gun fights you know we have no objection
to scenes where people are shooting a
gun repeatedly
and someone is hit and they fall down
and they're dead but we don't want to
show what a bullet actually does the
human body when it hits you you know we
like a little hole to appear in the
chest or something or at least element
of our people do and to my mind the more
I reflected on that the more I became
convinced that it's it's on some level
it's actually immoral here if we're
gonna show if you want to do a show that
has no violence I'm all in favor of that
but if you want to show guns or swords
and people killing each other with guns
our short show what guns and swords
actually do to human beings
you know show what war is actually like
if you're gonna do a war story you know
and show the horrors of war as well as
the glories of war and that's what I
tried to do in writing you know in Game
of Thrones rahkshi I think we have the
stereotype of violence in medieval times
how authentic is that yeah I'm glad to
say stereotype of course there were
feuds of course there was war and of
course it could have it was also brutal
when there was war but also in the
Middle Ages the preference was that one
would find a diplomatic solution because
when you think about it no one wants to
have a heap of corpses to clean up
afterwards right so is it just that
these violent stories are the ones that
survive more because they're more
exciting than the story of just ow we
reached an agreement and signed a treaty
I think that's again more refashioning
of the Middle Ages killing you know was
not an honorable thing to do mmm okay so
how much worse was it for women were
women bought and sold and traded yeah
that's the one thing of course in the
event of war women and children were
were in the tainted absolutely but of
course we have powerful women in the
Middle Ages that's not me that was not
and of course yeah I mean the earliest
powerful woman I know of this Queen
Elizabeth the first before that I don't
know many so what's what history am I
missing yeah so one one figure that I
find very interesting is Eleanor
accutane she was status' of Aquitaine
but in her own right which when she was
actually raining Aquitaine she in her
first husband was the King of France her
second was the king of England but she
also led armies strategically she didn't
fight on the battleground but she led
army strategically among others in the
Second Crusade
we have Joan of Arc the woman warrior
mm-hmm you have with gods Hildegard of
Bingen a visionary in in Germany who
sets out to to found her own monasteries
children
of those cases where you can draw from
them and still make plausible portrayals
of women in Game of Thrones
I don't think Game of Thrones needs to
be historically accurate because it's
it's so a fantasy world you know I agree
it just can be historically inspired yes
for sure for sure yeah well in this
final clip of my interview with george
RR martin which took place at his it is
his man cave in new mexico
i asked about infusing his passion for
outer space into stories such as Game of
Thrones so let's check it out these
these concepts are so vast that I don't
know how you write stories about them
with a meaningful human interaction you
know dealing with quasars and pulsars
and dark matter and that there's they're
amazing concepts but so difficult to
come to grips when you're writing a
story about human beings but there are
elements that to me are astronomical
right there's this long winter that's
coming and then when it comes is there
for a long time there's this huge sort
of ice wall I think of glaciers when I
think of this there's their tap roots
that allow me to Graf's grasp some
greater reality in which that world is
embedded what a lot of that of course is
based on magic because it is a it is a
fantasy and I gave a lot of magic it's
just science you haven't discovered yet
that earth to see corn thank you thank
you arthur c clarke
a sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
that's what so does the blade that that
i look at that and i say okay that
that's magic but they figured something
out and they can do that why is it any
different for me flicking a lighter okay
if I flipped a lighter in front of
cavemen that day they'd freak out right
right no they would write a story about
me with the lighter
if the historic ties they would improve
it though it wouldn't just be a lighter
it would be he could make fireballs glow
from his hands right right that's right
right so but there's more going on in
there there's other languages there is
squirrel building you have to create an
entire world and you can see if you are
engaged in world building you you have
to try to get everything right and
you're not gonna succeed you know
because I am NOT the font of all human
knowledge as much as I'm a research and
learn things you know plus they may pay
more closer attention to what you wrote
than you did
so yeah yeah so you will get letters you
know I tried to be very accurate for
example with horses a lot of fantasy
fans get horses all wrong our fantasy
writers they just make them you notice
these tireless beasts that can go
anywhere and and you know gallop for
seven days straight or whatever and
etcetera so I tried to get the horses
right but they're always things you
don't you know I tried to be research
the ships to get the ships right how the
weapons work if the horses wings on
their backs my axis I didn't know good
good alright so no this is I have an
interesting take on unicorns coming up
but uh in the new book oops
[Laughter]
when I think of these sort of fantasy
stories in almost all of them and
especially in Game of Thrones
there's the portrayal of some creature
in this case it's dragons it's a
creature that is not real and we know
it's not real as a consumer of the story
but the advantage of it not being real
is that you don't really understand it
you have no experience with it there's
no scientific analysis of it there's a
mystery to it and where there's mystery
for something that is large bigger than
you with teeth and flames there's fear
it's a metaphor for the sum of all of
our fears wrapped into this entity that
might make you behave right that might
make you think differently about the
things that promote life rather than
take life away so for me a dragon is a
force that acts on your behavior to be
good to do something right in the world
so in a way we need that force it's a
force of evil outside of our bodies and
a force of good within us and that
there's a cosmic perspective
[Applause]